too much [ __ ] too much pointing you sure
Oh what's the point
hey every backyard attention fresh
berries it's watermelon it's a button ah
hello hey guys I'm a B shart welcome to
Abby's kitchen it is so nice outside I
thought I'd head on over to the local
farmers market and pick up some of my
favorite little fruits here because
we're going to have a little backyard
barbecue and often we only put meat on
that grill we put some veggies on there
but I probably make some desserts here
with all of my favorite summers fruit
I've got three awesome healthiest summer
desserts here using the grill and you
are going to love them whoo okay first
up guys are going to make some a grilled
banana boat banana phone banana phone
so now a boat basically we're going to
take one of these little banana we're
going to surgically cut down the center
you don't want to cut into the banana
you just want to get into the peel a
little jacket and then we pry it open so
I'm going to get some natural peanut
butter here you can use whatever you
like but I love peanut butter I really
get blocked in there and may not look
very pretty at first but trust me going
to tape it is true so don't have some
dark chocolate here and cut it up nice
and fine you can use chocolate chips to
get in there load it up because this is
going to melt down and like that's the
best part
gonna turn it just like luxurious
chocolate peanut butter cool you see
what's happening I'm just thinking about
it perfect perfect okay I feel like that
that's a healthy amount of chocolate
now we
fold it up like a gift like this and
you're going to kind of like a present
banana present and I'm you just crimp it
over so everybody is sealed in
well that space tells us it will stay
all right now we go into the grill it's
like the new fashion coat time is viola
by man oh oh yeah that's the bananas
I've ever seen one we're going to finish
those off with some crushed peanuts and
some cacao nibs all right next about
these you pay pieces of watermelon and I
have to get some popsicle sticks and I
so please if you want to make sure you
soak your popsicle sticks also going to
burn on the grill so give them a good
soak for at least an hour some water and
of course it's going to be a little bit
of a challenge right so very carefully
watch a finger just going to get a hole
stuck in there but you can then Lodge
that in so now we bought a watermelon
pop this is often really all on its own
there's really nothing no need to do
much more but we're going to take this
to the next level now we're going to
make a little mixture here with some
lime juice got some agave a little pinch
of chilli
I like it spicy so I'm going to have a
lot of excess and I go do a little
sensitive mix this guy up until a jahve
is all alright so I'm just going to
brush this in our agave lime juice chili
mixture here and I'm gonna get this onto
the groove
[Music]
now we're going to mix together some of
toasted coconut and grated lime draft
I'm just going to mix this together now
we have to decorate so we're going to
brush this again add a little bit of
that same agave next year give it a next
a little coating here
rizz tip then into our coconut lime next
year hello sticks all on there alright
finally we're going to do my double
berry crumble so I've got some beautiful
blueberries we're gonna throw some
berries down right into the center of
this foil pack raspberries going down
some all into the center like that a
little bit of our tapioca starch it's
going to help to thicken everything up
once those juices start coming out and
some coconut oil but a tablespoon so a
little bit of maple syrup and I've got
some granola here that's our crumble
there's no need to go to all the trouble
of making me consist wraps because we're
going to make this a super super low
detta
now you make a pretty little packet and
this is great if you were camping and
you see little sweet fix you can make
this so easily on your campfire all
right this is going into a BBQ throw a
little bit more granola on top just for
a little extra crunch got a beautiful
dollop here of fresh meat whipped
coconut cream give me a little mint
sprig to get fancy
sweet crunchy mmm creamy as well that
makes coconut cream what more could you
want
we've got three awesome easy willable
recipes that are perfect for your
outside barbecue if you guys like these
recipes be sure to give this video the
thumbs up leave me a comment below from
your favorite grilled fruit recipes
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen fine
[Music]
let's get at this get at me well get at
me
nope yeah me yeah me but I just put
peanut Barbra here Oh gross you get a
spoon look even if you don't have one
you just you get one somehow somebody
got me a spoon you guys will see some
fun let's kick some big ones that we
recycle it's only here